quand j'étais que chaque 10 mafieux
[Musique]
elle est tournée et il est prêt il
attend juste que ya des salles de cinéma
pour l'accueillir mais ça s'appelle
debout les pannes et s'est consacré aux
métiers d'auxiliaire de vie sociale
d'accompagnantes d'enfants en situation
de handicap et ça rebondit sur la phrase
du manuel mâcon qui nous lisent et il ya
un an notre pays repose tout entier sur
ces femmes et ces hommes que nous autres
ne me reconnaissent et rémunère si mal
et même baiia pour qu'elle soit mieux
rémunéré mieux reconnus et donc c'est
l'histoire de cette bagarre ouais
non non mais j'ai même dit annoncé
officiellement que j'étais pas candidat
non non ceci dit ça fait bien pour le
vendre un livre sur toi
[Musique]
si j'étais emmanuel macron ou bruno le
maire je saisirai cette main là le plus
vite possible pour tenter que cette
promesse devienne une réalité et voir si
c'est du flan ou c'est vrai mais il faut
il faut essayer quoi
[Musique]
ah c'est carrément mais quand ça c'est
pas la fin des vols intérieurs c'est
quand même parce qu'il ya des régions
qui est qui réclame sans doute d'être
desservies par l'avion parce qu'elles
sont peu accessibles notamment parce que
on ne construit pas les milieux train
qu'il faudrait ou alors on les laisse se
pérennité mais il ya deux ans quand je
proposais ça et bien j'étais quasiment
avec mes revers j'étais un irresponsable
intitulé finalement
[Musique]
en tout cas moi ce qui me préoccupe
c'est est ce que on va retrouver le
chemin des classes populaires
l'union n'est pas une condition
suffisante peut-être que c'est
nécessaire mais c'est pas suffisant
pourrait se demander comment on va aller
parler aux gens
[Musique]